[Music]
I'm here an AT&T Stadium this is the
home of the Dallas Cowboys it's a
spectacular enclosed stadium and of
course the AI goes immediately to this
massive screen right here one of the
largest diamond vision screens in the
world it's 72 feet high by 160 feet wide
it weighs 1.2 million pounds if this
screen were made of meat
it would be a major health hazard so why
am I here because I want to take the 8th
wonder of the world one of mankind's
greatest technological achievements and
use it to play video games
get in here Aaron that's right it's
another episode of clueless gamer
[Applause]
one of the most advanced technological
achievements in the world and yet the
irony you turn it on using a clapper wow
this is mind-blowing this is incredible
this is causing my heart to defibrillate
we're in ATT stadium let's play some
football Madden 25 that's right you want
to select your team here just go yeah I
want to be the Patriots all right
Patriots I'm gonna play the Cowboys
hello friends Jim Nantz a local bill
sense partner good to be with you today
look they've caught how phil simms has
dead eyes here we go it's let's stick
around
Leon watch you do it now with a chance
to return ok then they're just talking
about Giselle you really married did you
so yeah I mean so like will you go home
Giselle's there yeah but when you leave
in the morning she's the up Giselle's
there
they'll be running yeah and they'll be
symbols above the receipt okay okay
match this little before they snap it
next time we're all good to the bride
can't they protect her
as soon as I could look yeah I'm waiting
way too long okay when they show it in
slow motion it looks like I'm waiting
for a bus
okay playing football on this screens a
little obvious let's do something a
little less obvious oh yeah all right so
this game's called flower your that
flower petal so you can go up and down
you're trying to hit other flower petals
thing to help them to let them join you
whoa
there you go you got another flower
petal oh my god there's no way these
guys weren't high when they invented I
don't recommend this game if you have
allergies if you experience an erection
for more than nine hours consult your
doctor oh look at that oh wow the kids
are spelling out my name if I put the
kids to sleep
look at them all
hi kids what a beautiful I'm playing
with these petals children are lying in
the field we've taken over football
let's try something more intense yeah
welcome to Need for Speed rivals what
happened yes yes sorry be great if your
battery was low with all of this
yeah fifty million dollars of technology
at our disposal in your triple-a
batteries Need for Speed rivals so r2 is
gonna be your gasps l2 is like your
reverse and then this one I'm gonna need
reverse
poorly designed Road the alignment of
the car is off
all right that guy get that guy get it
oh I got him
flat four nitro
shut up shut up that tree had to come
down anyway
we're past him with Matson we wrecked
okay what was our score ah that's the
number of things I hit four point eight
miles but memorable miles I won't forget
that drive neither will anybody who
lives in that area play a waiting game
yes
one of the classic fighting games Street
Fighter 2 yeah all right so pick your
guy you can you can scroll around with
this trying to get this anybody that
reminds me of me I'll be this guy
there's no fiercer warrior than Ken
maybe Brad what America USA
[Music]
oh alright this is the best game we
played so far these people I like a
fighting game oh my god these countries
fascinate me what's Friday brought USSR
okay their treaty this is the most
depressing view of Brezhnev I've ever
seen oh my god that's my move
yeah
what do you think I've played video
games with you a lot this has been the
most fun I highly recommend that all of
you watching go out and rent an NFL
stadium cleared of all personnel and
play video games I'm a giant diamond
here if you can't afford that you could
try getting a basketball arena I
wouldn't go smaller than a basketball
arena that's the lowest I'd go this was
fantastic
peace out Tupac
[Applause]
[Music]